hallo Gentleman erstmal ein großes Lob
an deine übergeile stimme ich finde sie
ein bisschen die von Bob mal was ich
übertrieben geil finde weil ich Bob Fan
bin ja also nur zu meiner Frage ich
schon immer wissen wollte so von dir wie
wurdest du eigentlich entdeckt weil ich
meine es ist einfach übertrieben schwer
in diesem musikbsiness entdeckt zu
werden weil ich ma selber jetzt schon
weil Musik so wie wurde ich entdeckt ich
weiß nicht ob ich entdeckt Odde so ich
glaube es ist ganz wichtig ähm ja mit
das Umfeld ist ganz wichtig Leute um
dich zu haben die dich auf die nächste
Stufe bringen so und ich muss aber sagen
ich war in der Zeit wo es vielleicht
einfacher war ähm wenn du eine
Leidenschaft hast für die Musik dich zu
etablieren so
bei mir war es so dass ich ähm mit
verschiedenen Soundsystems erstmal durch
die Lande durchs Land geturt bin und
reggy Musik aufgelegt habe und dabei
immer so ein bisschen gesungen habe m
und dann war so dass ich Max von
Freundeskreis kennengelernt habe der
meine Sachen gut fand und da war für
mich so ein bisschen der Einstieg also
ein anderer Künstler ist ganz wichtig so
ähm bei mir war es auch nicht so dass
ich irgendwie meine Demotapes an
Plattenfirmen geschickt habe und die
dann gesagt komm wir nehmlich jetzt
unter Vertrag so sondern ich habe ganz
viel durchs live spielen erreicht so das
heißt ich habe Demotapes an Veranstalter
geschickt so die haben meine Musik
gehört und haben gesagt ich glaube der
kann uns die Bude rocken das habe ich
dann auch gemacht und m das live spielen
ist ganz ganz ganz wichtig so von daher
irgendwie guck dass du eine Band
zusammenstellst oder irgendwie mach
coole Musik auch mit DJ irgendwie und
versuch Gigs zu an Start zu bringen und
weiß ich nicht also ich finde auch ein
bisschen schade dass gerade so bei
MySpace und so vielleicht die die die
Klasse so ein bisschen in der Masse
verloren geht weil einfach so viel da
ist aber wenn du Talent und Leidenschaft
hast und das richtige Umfeld dann müst
du irgendwann dein Ding
machen